[Music]
today i'll be talking about the r
package validation framework which is a
project i've been working on for the
past a little over
a year or so now um and i'm really
excited to share with you all
what we've been working on and the
updates that have come out of this
so uh my name is ellis hughes i'm a
statistical programmer i have a
background working in statistical
genetics
currently i work at fred hutch under
sharp working on hiv vaccine research
i'm pretty heavily involved in the our
community and the seattle or one of the
seattle us r organizers
i also am one of the organizers for the
cascadia archonf
and i also run a screencast called tidyx
where we go through and explain how our
code works
usually from tidy tuesday submissions so
you can find me on twitter
at ellis underscore hughes so
a common question that any of us if
we've ever tried to introduce new
software into the pharma world is
is it validated that's a question that
we're always going to be getting is it
validated
but what is validation that can mean
different things to different people
yes there's an official definition but
it means different things to different
people
so the as i understand that the uh the
definition of validation is establishing
documentary evidence that our software
performs some sort of process procedure
activity
and compliance with our specifications
with a high degree of assurance so in
layman's terms
we're creating documents to prove that
our software does what we say it does
but why do we even care about validation
why is that question even
asked well a lot of people refer to the
fact that we have to
validate our software for fda submission
but there's a lot of unspoken benefits
around validation that don't always get
talked about such as improved quality
and safety of our code because we've
gone through and checked it we're
confident in the quality of the code
as well as the fact that it'll return
proper results it results in faster
processing because we already have this
code now set up we can use it across
multiple projects
and trust that it'll um work and then it
also promotes trust
because we've performed this validation
we've gone through and vetted it the
best
to our abilities so we're confident then
we when we give it an input it'll give
us a consistent output
as well as throw an error when things
are go out of bounds
but validation practice can be a really
high bar and there's a lot of documents
that go into creating validation because
first you have to fill out a smart
form for specifications planned uses
environments you're going to be using it
in
then write out some your code based on
those specifications record the function
authorship in some external file
potentially an excel file then get
another form to document your test cases
testing
testing environment how you plan on
doing your testing
then maybe the last form to show how
your testing plan is comprehensive that
you're proving that all your
specifications
are being met through your testing plan
have a third party come through and
manually evaluate your tests and get
screenshots for results
and then you have to review your
documentation combine it into a final
validation packet for release but
information is shared across all of
these documents so anytime one of them
updates you need to go back and update
it and if you've manually evaluated all
your tests
and had to make an update you're going
to have to go through and rerun
everything so it's incredibly
inefficient
and at any time it can feel like game
over because you're just redoing your
work over and over
again but today i want to tell you that
validation
and r can be best friends they can work
together
to provide a validation framework such
that we can
achieve all the goals of validation
without the
as much additional stress and work that
can be involved with that
using a combination of our markdown test
that and oxygen 2
we can essentially make validation push
button for validation
and generate a document that looks like
this where we're able to capture
a sig a place for signatures for
everyone that's been involved with the
project
we're able to have information about the
environment which we performed our
validation in
record who wrote what pieces of the the
project the specs the functions the test
cases the code
as well as share what the coverage is
between our specs and our test cases
and finally record all of all of our
content here including our test results
all at the click of a button without
having to redo as much work
and this is the r package validation
framework so there's five key elements
to the framework there's recording your
specs writing your code
recording your test cases writing your
test code and finally generating the
documentation
the advantage of using this framework is
well it's integrated into the pro
the our package development process it
goes it takes you from the beginning of
the ideation of i want to create a
package
all the way through the process to
creating a package that now you've
validated it's native to our programmers
it lives this this framework lives
within the our package itself
so you don't have to leave your our
package environment in order to perform
your validation or have
all the documents in there it allows for
iterative development because we don't
have docs living across multiple
locations it it allows us to update
pieces without having to make sure that
we've updated the five different
other documents with that piece of
information it's reusable and extensible
because it's reliant on code we're able
to just rerun things
and make sure and it'll just run and
work and it's extensible if you want to
move pieces out of your package
into a more utility focused package you
can totally do that
and just copy out your test cases and
specs and whatnot into that new package
and you don't have to be
putting a whole new round of effort into
doing that
so we're going to start at the beginning
which is specifications now
specifications define the expectations
of a package
so you kind of think of that as like the
blueprints for your package so it's
really defining
what is the goal of your package a good
specification is it
is going to have several different
elements it's like what will the thing
be doing
what are the expected inputs what are
the expected outputs
what are warnings or errors that should
be triggered when things like letting us
know
letting the user know when things are
going out of bounds but critically a
specification will not rely on external
knowledge you can assume that there's
basic knowledge
in the the programmer side of things but
do not assume that they have contextual
knowledge around
the statistics or the process you may be
trying to
create into your r package so if i were
to be writing a specification for my
presentation today
i'll say my presentation will cover the
contents of my team's approach to
validation
it'll be roughly 15 to 20 minutes long
and it'll be entertaining
now when i go to convert that into a
specification file that i'd save into my
package
it needs to have these several different
pieces here first it needs to be machine
readable
because we're going to need to be able
to read that later on
it's going to need to be independent so
we don't want to have multiple
specification files that
link back to one another because that
can create codependencies
and make it difficult to separate pieces
out and then close proximity to the test
so we want to have it saved within our r
package
so that it lives where the programmers
are doing their work
when we're documenting our
specifications other than the actual
specifications themselves we really want
to be capturing information such as
who wrote those specifications and when
it was written
so if i were to be taking the
specification that i wrote earlier and
converting it into what i'd be using for
the our package validation framework
i would use something like this and it's
written in markdown where we have i have
a header at the very top there where i
have the section where
i wrote that spec and i wrote it on this
date my specifications are my
presentation will clearly explain the
validation procedure
it'll be 15 to 20 minutes long and it'll
be entertaining and i'll measure that by
causing at least three people to laugh
and optionally spec 1.4 fame glamour and
maybe start at brandon's accessory chain
we'll see
all right so let's get down to business
we have our specs it's code development
time you know the piece we've all been
waiting for
and don't worry i'm not going to sit
here and tell you how to write code
i'm going to trust that you're going to
be following good programming practices
everything around that however what i am
going to talk about is documenting your
code for validation
and what we want to be capturing around
that is who wrote the code
when they wrote it and making sure to
update the documentation of
ownership whenever the code gets updated
and the way we're going to go about
doing that is using
oxygen tags so rock if you're writing
your code according to good programming
practice
you're going to be adding documentation
around that and a lot of folks are going
to use
oxygen to do so so we suggest using
these two rock student tags act
section last updated by and at section
last updated date
to capture this information and the
value of doing this is it provides close
proximity to the task
whoever is actually working on the
function at that time
doesn't have to go to an external uh
word or document to make sure to update
oh i updated
uh this function here and this is when i
did it
no it's actually right there with the
function so it makes it simple to do
it's a natural extension of the
documentation already being performed
because we're already using
oxygen too and an added benefit is it
adds documentation to the functions
itself because it's a oxygen
dot or oxygen tag it's actually when you
compile your documentation it'll be
added in there
so this is a simple function that i
wrote it's a joke where you have a punch
line
and a setup but really what we care
about is this lap
these two roxane tags here so i was the
one that wrote this function and this is
when i wrote it
and it's a very simple function but say
joe king
came through and updated my joke to make
it so that i had a new parameter so it
would uh the user could specify how long
it
waited before it delivered the punchline
well joe updated that he updated
his normal oxygen tags but then he also
updated
the updated by and date to joe and when
he updated it
and now that we now that that's in there
when he regenerates the documentation
the help pages have who wrote that
function and when they updated it so you
are now the owner of that
that function for validation purposes
cool all right so now we're going to
connect the dots
so we have our code and we have our
specs but we need to prove that we've
met our specs
and the way you do that is through test
cases so test cases prove
what you wanted to do to what you did
now a single test case can satisfy
multiple specifications if it's covering
a lot of
the the functions that you're going to
be using stuff like that you can prove
that you've met your specifications
however every single specification must
be satisfied by at least
one test case and the risk of a
specification
drives then the level of testing
performs the number of times you'll be
testing that function with new inputs
now a good test case will uh will share
which specifications are being met and
how they're being met
detail the required setup so if there's
any data that need to be loading in if
there's any environment variables need
to be setting
that it'll detail this is what you need
to be doing it'll be
it's a recipe really for how to get from
this setup input into the desired output
with clear expectations for what you're
going to be testing against
so if you're reading in a data set you
want to be clear to say
rather than saying check the length go
check that the length of
this data set is 34 rows
but critically there's no code provided
because you want whoever is going to be
performing the test testing to not be
able to copy and paste the code in
because then you can actually
test it when you're documenting your
test cases we're going to capture the
same information that we have been
who wrote the test and when they wrote
it but we're also going to capture
which specifications are being satisfied
because that can update as tests update
and we can use oxygen tag surprise
surprise to do that so at section last
updated by at section last updated date
and at section specification coverage
and so if i were to be writing a test
case for my presentation today
i have my sections at the top here so
i wrote this test case this is when i
wrote it and these are the
the test case and which specs are being
covered i have a setup where i create my
presentation
then i will go through and prove that i
met my specifications
by my first test test that the
presentation was informative
by asking my audience that they what
they learned
i'll time my presentation make sure it's
between 15 and 20 minutes long
and test it as entertaining by counting
the number of chuckles
from the audience which unfortunately i
can't hear you right now hopefully
you're laughing
or uh when i practice it to my
significant other the number of eye
rolls and trust me
there were a few of them all right so
now we have all
the setup here so now we're going to
fill in the lines with test coding so
test coding is the actual implementation
of the test cases in code
we're going to be then recording the
results to prove that we've met our
specifications but
very very importantly a third party
doing this so somebody that was not
involved in the writing of the package
or the writing of the test cases can now
go through and perform the testing they
could have written the specifications
but all right so the benefits of doing
this test coding is going to help
resolve interpretation errors in your
documentation and examples
because this person doesn't actually
know how to
use your package they're able to they're
going to be using your documentation to
see
how they're supposed to be achieving the
test cases that you lay out
and if they have any they can raise any
questions about it about your
documentation and go this wasn't very
clear to me
because you're as the author
intrinsically understand how the
function is supposed to be behaving
this new person doesn't know that so
they can ask you to improve your
documentation or examples
if the test case itself isn't very clear
they're going to come to their own
conclusion and so
then it's going to fail and they are
able to you're able to go back and then
improve your test cases
and a failing test case is not
necessarily a bad thing it just means
that you need to improve your
documentation
uh and then any uh any interpretation
errors in your specifications
if they didn't write their
specifications well they can once again
go back and help improve those
and then in general it helps identify
improvements so if your code
runs slowly or if an argument isn't
incredibly clear they're
able to go back and go hey we were
missing this argument here can you
please add that in
as i was going through the test cases it
didn't really make a whole bunch of
sense to be able to have to set it up
this way
so it really allows for iterative
improvement before you even get to the
first release
so we're going to use a combination of
tesla and surprise surprise for oxygen
2.
we're going to document our test code
with who wrote the test code and when
they wrote it
using the same oxygen tag plus updated
by and last updated date
and so this is an example of what a some
test code might look like so we have
the um the header here at the top and so
each test
piece will have its own test flat
section here
it's exactly like any other test that uh
but we have this left that last updated
by just her
uh on the last updated date here's the
expectation
the test they have the code they run and
the expectations
completely like any other test that's
set up
and the reason we're using tesla it's a
familiar framework it's used by a ton of
packages on crane right now it's
it's this de facto standard basically at
this point for for unit testing so we're
going to
kind of steal that and use it for for
our purposes it can also be run and
developed either interactively or in
batch so we don't
have to have somebody manually running
it but they can manually run it as
they're building up their test
but the the real and the big reason why
we use
test that is for the recorder objects
that live and test that so
uh reporter objects are a special object
that live inside tesla that help track
and test each expectation and reports
whether they succeed
or if they do fail why they failed and
that's very important because we need to
track that for our validation purposes
so a standard reporter object output
kind of looks like this so if you've
ever built a package and done like
control shift t
after you put unit tests in there you've
actually used a reporter object you just
didn't really know
because it's under the hood but what we
were able to do
is we took we execute the reporter
object but then we use a custom
function to extract the results for us
and make a nice table
that shows which test was run whether
the results were as expected or if they
were different
what what they were that was different
and then a pass or fail
um and we can put that into a table
right proof is in the pudding so what do
we have so far
we have our specifications we have our
code we have a test cases in our test
code but
you know as we said validation was all
about documenting that we did all this
and this is our validation documentation
so we're going to use our markdown to
create
a vignette where we're going to record
all of the all the information that
we've created so far
into a vignette we're going to have a
sign-off slash approval section
based on your organizational requirement
we're going to capture
environmental information such as the r
version and package dependency versions
in the our markdown because it's dynamic
it'll update whenever you rerun
your uh validation documentation and
here you can also capture any other
organizational requirements that might
have been found in any other documents
for validation then using our markdown
we're going to dynamically read in our
specifications
once again it was very critical that
they were machine readable scrape the
test code for authorship
read in the test cases and drop those
into the
uh document and then execute all the
test code and capture those results into
the tables that we saw
and so this is the general format of
what you might see your package as under
the vignettes folder
we're going to have the validation rmd
which is going to have all that
code in setup and recording of the
environments this is then going to be
the results typically in the pdf
we're going to have our validation
folder where we have our specs our test
cases and our test code and all the
content underneath
there so all together now so like i said
we're going to use our markdown
test that and oxygen 2 and with their
powers combined
we're able to generate a reproducible
validation report at the click of a
button
or at the build of a package because it
lives in the vignettes folder
and when you build it you can tell it to
execute your vignette so you can make
sure that you don't have
an our package that has failed its
validation
and we generate this exact same report
that we had before
but now you know where all this came
from we wrote in these uh the signature
pages here
this validation environment was scraped
or was generated at the build of this
document
we pulled in all this information about
who wrote these specifications who wrote
the functions who wrote the test cases
who wrote the test code
we were able to show coverage of all the
specifications to the test cases
and we're able to drop it all into this
document
dynamically we don't have to manually go
through and update it every time
okay so that's that's the framework
where are we at now
so currently i'm working on a white
paper with a team from fuse to
describe the framework process in more
detail as well as generalizing and
recording the optimal processes
that we suggest you follow when you're
using this framework and it's very much
under construction hopefully it'll be
coming out later this year
really excited for this we're also
working on a val tools r package
so this is going to be based on the
white paper it's very much in progress
but it'll provide tooling that's not
currently available
with use this or dev tools to help folks
perform their validations
using this framework um and hopefully
that'll be coming out later this year as
well
so many thanks to all the folks that
have been involved with this framework
uh
fred hutch so marie vandetuli anthony
williams jimmy barthy raphael
alicia shannon paul and kate as well as
the folks that are on the fuse our
package validation framework working
group because you really helped me
figure out how to expand this framework
and really make it more general so it
works for more folks
so hopefully now you understand that
validation and r can truly live together
forever
thank you very much for having me uh
talk today
our studio as well as procagia and
putting this together you can find uh
more code in this presentation at
github.com slash the bioengineers slash
validation
underscore rstudio underscore 2021.
thank you so much
[Music]
you